et on en parle tout de suite avec nos
invités benjamin morel et le docteur en
sciences politiques et emery glissé à
secrétaire général de think tank le
millénaire
bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
en direct assure rt france pourquoi
emmanuel macron il ne livre pas ses
intentions en vue de la présidentielle
d'argent la morale est ce que c'est
finalement le privilège du président
s'ils voulaient le président de la
république souhaite vème république il a
un côté un peu janus c'est à dire que
d'un côté il est le chef de l'état tient
qu'à l'unité des français mais il a une
autre facette une facette plus chef de
gouvernement en chef de majorité ou en
effet il devient clivant dans une
période de crise particulièrement mais
en réalité dans n'importe quelle période
préélectorale vous avez un intérêt pour
le président a joué sur cette ambiguïté
c'est pour ça que vous avez des
déclarations de candidature est vraiment
un président qui revient dans l'arène
politique immédiate que extrêmement
tardive parce que lorsque vous devenez
rennes en candidat réellement et bien
vous perdez justement tout s'est tu
auras tout ce ralliement sous drapeau
qui va être la caractéristique de ce
chef de l'état qui est censé faire
l'unité donc vous avez une entrée en
campagne tardive encore plus en période
de crise encore plus en temps de
présidence de la paix de l'union
européenne quelque chose sur lequel veut
capitaliser emmanuel macron donc très
clairement on a là quelque chose d'assez
classique quelque chose c'était évoquez
dans votre reportage qui pose question
du point de vue du temps de parole de la
manière dont on considère ensuite les
différents déterminants de la campagne
mais qui a été vécu également penser pas
d'essai se
sait c'est vrai lacroix a présenté les
grands axes
ce qu'il souhaite pour l'europe lorsque
la france prendra la présidence
tournante
de l'union européenne justement à ce
qu'il veut se laisser le temps vous
pensez de montrer ce qu'il peut faire
avant de se porter candidat pour la
présidentielle
oui tout à fait il a tout à fait raison
de choisir son moment de choisir le
moment où il se portera candidat est
pour rappel la déclaration de
candidature de françois mitterrand 88
pour sa campagne de réélection considéré
comme une référence en terme de campagne
de réélection n'était intervenue que le
22 avril le 22 mars donc quasiment à une
campagne éclair de quelques mois et ça
permet au présent la république de jouer
sur un choc d'image entre des candidats
qui vont déjà commencé à batailler à
apporter des propositions à s'attaquer à
à lancer des attaques ad hominem alors
que l'ue serait dans une position de
hauteur à défendre des intérêts de la
france a parlé au nom de la france et de
l'europe et finalement être au dessus de
la mêlée ne peut encore descendre dans
l'arène et finalement descendre de
manière très ciblée quand il y en aura
décidé le moment le timing est dans les
meilleures conditions ils bénéficient de
cet avantage là mais dont tous les
autres présidents sortants ont bénéficié
et puis finalement ils n'ont pas tous
gagné peu ont été réélus donc il faut
pas voir ça comme une grande asymétrie
dans la façon de faire campagne comme
une tonne ou finalement l'écart du
présent de réflexion différente des
autres candidats elles ont ses avantages
et ses défauts alors du côté en tout cas
des candidats déclarés et dans les rangs
de l'opposition on lui reproche benjamin
morel an prochain emmanuel macron de
jouer là dessus justement de profiter de
ce statut de président pour faire
campagne de façon cachée est-ce qu'il
peut tenir cette pression suffisamment
longtemps
oui bien sûr qu'il fait company 2 fait
son de façon indirecte à travers sa sas
être présent à un public qui joue sur
l'international c'était dit me joue sur
le contraste avec les autres candidats
parce que évidemment quand on préside l
europe comme rencontrer les chefs d'état
étrangers etc
c'est une manière de crédibiliser votre
candidature vous êtes chef de l'état
donc vous pouvez l'être demain qui est
très classique et l'opposition peut
évidemment le lui reprocher la réalité
c'est qu'encore une fois à ses
prédécesseurs ont fait la même chose il
appartenait au parti qui souvent le lui
reproche et si jamais valérie pécresse
anne hidalgo ou marine le pen était
président de la république il ferait
également la même chose alors ensuite
c'est quelque chose qui est tout même à
double tranchant c'est à dire que la
volonté de se mettre en avant
et de se mettre un petit peu or hors les
clous parce que emmanuel macron ne va à
débattre directement avec valérie
pécresse marine le pen eric zemmour
avant le débat d'entre deux tours c'est
une façon également de se protéger mais
c'est également une manière de ne pas
répondre directement et donc à partir de
là d'être taxé souvent et bien de deux
d'être en prise moins directe avec les
préoccupations des français à l'instant
t il va envoyer des lieutenants sur ces
sujets mais c'est malgré tout
relativement problématique parce que
quoi qu'on en pense eh bien les affaires
internationales les affaires européennes
sont toujours en queue de classement
dans les enquêtes d'opinion parmi les
préoccupations des français ça joue sur
les dos ça joue sur la posture et c'est
important pour une élection
présidentielle mais quand vous parlez
sécurité quand vous parlez pouvoir
d'achat être président de l'union
européenne ça ne vous donne pas un réel
avantage comparatif donc là aussi il ya
des avantages il ya également des
inconvénients et comme ça bien été dit
par par mon interlocuteur on joue avec
les cartes que l'on a c'est parti alors
le président ne s'est pas encore déclaré
candidat mais c'est certain il ya aucun
doute à ce niveau un coup de théâtre
finalement de non candidature n'est pas
envisageable aymeric du sein
il faut pas avoir de certitude où tout
peut arriver mais la tendance sur
laquelle on assiste c'est plutôt
les soutiens du présent gratuits qui
sont tout soit prêt au moment où le
président de république donne le feu
vert et descendre dans l'arène
finalement tout sera prêt un peu comme
ce qu'on avait pu à observer en 1988
avec françois mitterrand c'est pas tant
le président la république qui a envie
d'être président mais plutôt un appel
des français du peuple n'attend à son
camp pour qu'il stoppe en dentelle
candidat unique a que
comme ça qu'on dit c'est hélas c'est à
dire un camp qu'ils soient très très
solidaire de son chef et qui attendent
l'entrée l'entrée en campagne du
président la république qui est un appel
des français sait ce qui l'attend le
président il a multiplié en tout cas les
opérations séduction var alain morel
c'est vrai beaucoup de déplacements en
france est-ce que son bilan finalement
il est à son avantage au moment où on se
parle on voit que le gilet jaune bat à
nouveau le pavé les samedis il ya aussi
la réforme des retraites qui est loin de
faire l'unanimité
et puis aussi la gestion de la pandémie
aussi qu'il suscite de la contestation
le bilan est presque secondaire on va
éviter ce qui va compter c'est la
manière dont on perçoit le bilan est
donc ce qu'il en reste vous savez il ya
un antique avec d'intéressants fait sur
les élections allemandes la première
élection dans la réélection de gerhard
schröder on se demande où vous avez des
vous avez des inondations massives
notamment sax à l'époque et gerhard
schröder qui apparaissait totalement au
fond des sondages à ce moment là tout
d'un coup remonté il va ensuite être
désignés vont être avec le spd pour un
second mandat l'électorat se prononce en
réalité sur la perception qu'il a
maintenant du chef de l'état et pas la
perception qu'il avait ya six mois et
dans cette perception eh bien vous avez
tout un tas d'éléments qui sont à ces
impondérables vous avez des éléments qui
sont liées à
la dynamique de campagne des éléments
qui vont être lié également au programme
ou slogan qui vont être lancés à la
sensation plus ou moins sous qu'une
alternative au possible et est possible
qu'elle ne l'est pas ou quelques
éléments qui vont marquer la fin de
campagne prenez actuellement
l'appréciation des français sur la
gestion de la crise sanitaire elle était
très négative et un nom aujourd'hui elle
est plutôt positive majoritairement à
tort ou à raison mais elle est malgré
tout plutôt positive donc c'est ça qui
profondément va jouer et en effet je
rejoins tout à fait ce que les aymeric
dû glisser tout à l'heure l'intérêt de
la majorité à ce stade là est bien c'est
de préparer le terrain de préparer
justement ce terrain qui va être
favorable c'est a priori qui vont être
favorable pour le jour où emmanuel
macron va dire bon d'accord visiblement
les français même je vais être candidat
cela n'apparaisse pas que cela
n'apparaisse pas comme quelque chose de
totalement absurde de totalement
déconnecté de l'actualité et du
sentiment profond des français et qui
est comme ça un terrain un terreau sur
lequel est bien cette idée puisse
pousser à dans l'ensemble de l'opinion
évidemment mais dans son socle électoral
qui aujourd'hui reste assez solide et
qui peut relativement de quelques
pourcents de quelques pourcents de
quelques dizaines de pourcents peut-être
c'est l'argent alors qui dit préparer le
terrain en tout cas aux fins de la
majorité présidentielle de ses soutiens
le fait de ne pas se présenter tout de
suite ça laisse aussi le temps
d'observer les sondages que l'on peut
voir ces derniers temps qui place par
exemple valérie pécresse au second tour
de la présidentielle elle aimerait
glisser avec le président de la
république voir comment évolue aussi
eric zemmour et marine le pen
là il ya des challengers de d'emmanuel
macron
la l'élection ce toit
pour emmanuel macron c'est bien de bien
identifier sa cible et qu'elle est
finalement le socle électoral la cible
électorale qui doit viser de façon
prioritaire pour élargir son spectre
électorale pour l'instant ce que l'on
observe dans l'est dans les études
d'opinion c'est que malgré la poussée et
l'effet primaire pour valérie pécresse
qui a beaucoup augmenté son score est
bien récupérer entre 1/3 et 50% des
électeurs de françois fillon qui
seraient tentés par emmanuel macron le
présent la réplique ne décroche pas des
bénéficie d'un effet vote utile du côté
d'une gauche qui dit viser pour faire
barrage à des candidatures qui peuvent
être perçus comme très anxiogène par un
électorat de gauche comme celle de
marine le pen et d'eric zemmour
finalement le présent appliquée dans
cette position où il va devoir continuer
à la fois séduire un électorat plutôt
chrétien démocrate de centre droit et en
même temps bénéficier toujours d'un
effet vote utile d un électorat de
gauche c'est plutôt abandonné en fait
d'un point de vue plutôt social
démocrate qui arrivent pas ouvert une
incarnation au tour d'anne hidalgo de
l'année jadot qui est plutôt fracturé
donc réussir à toujours avoir ces deux
volets faire une seule en même temps
qu'il avait réussi à faire en 2017 une
partie des leptons
deux cents un an plus tôt vous avez
vraiment peu perdu à aymeric et c'est
benjamin morel pour conclure c'est
important ce que vient de d'expliquer m
réglisse et en vue justement du second
tour les alliances possibles les
ralliements possible pour emmanuel
macron alors les ralliements soit non
c'est à dire que dès le moment où vous
avez des consignes de vote elles sont
pas forcément suivies l'important c'est
pas ce que font les candidats à
l'important c'est pas ce que font donc
les barons important c'est ce que font
les électeurs est aujourd'hui en effet
il ya plusieurs enjeux pour emmanuel
macron c'est à dire que si jamais vous
avez une candidature de la droite de la
droite face à lui il faut qu'une partie
substantielle de l'électorat se
raccrocher lui et donc il ne peut pas
non plus trop se gauchiser entre
guillemets en même temps on voit qu'il
un déficit dans l'électorat de gauche
aujourd'hui quand vous prenez les
enquêtes récentes mettant en scène un
second tour macron le pen vous voyez que
vous avez un électeur mélenchon sur
trois qui votent macron 1 qui vote le
pen qui s'abstiennent vous avez un
électeur jadot et hidalgo sur deux qui
votent macro la majorité s'abstient donc
aujourd'hui il ya des difficultés pour
emmanuel macron en vue d'un second tour
et là pour le coup marine le pen a une
carte à jouer c'est cette d'ailleurs
qu'elle joue depuis 2010 7,2 à la fois
modération et d activation d'une forme
de
vote front républicain face à elle en
cas de second tour contre emmanuel
macron ça a plutôt bien fonctionné il
est probable que là-dessus la
candidature zemmour l'aide au corps
parce que ça fonctionne plus la droite a
d'autres soucis vous avez un logiciel de
kreisker tout de même très libéral
est-ce que ça permettra de conduire
justement à est ce que ça ne permettra
pas de emmanuel macron de rallier une
partie du vote de gauche ça aussi ça va
être un enjeu ça va être un enjeu pour
la droite à part être plus désirable qu
emmanuel macron un électorat de gauche
pour l'instant il fallait gagner la
primaire maintenant il va falloir gagner
50% des votants pour celui qui voudra
l'emporter sur ses manuels macro merci à
vous battre la morale docteur en
sciences politiques et merci à vous
également enrique glissé je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire général estime donc
le millénaire